other videos we have talked about the
early history of islam which really
revolves around the life of muhammad and
muhammad as we talked about was born
roughly in 570 and dies in 632. and on
this timeline here the white period is
before according to muslim traditions
that he started having the revelations
from god and the brown period is when
he's having these revelations and he's
starting to be the leader of this
nascent muslim community
now what we see here in this dark brown
is what was in control of this muslim
community at the time of muhammad's
death and you see even by that period
they had control of a good chunk of the
arabian peninsula and what's
particularly surprising is how fast
islam spread shortly after that the next
period after muhammad dies the
leadership of the community of the ummah
goes to the caliphs and this actually
becomes a contentious issue that we'll
talk about in other videos it's the seed
of the eventual schism between the
sunnis and the shias but this next
period the rashidun or the rightly
guided kalis khalif means successors
essentially successors to muhammad under
these four khalifs you see islam spread
from as far west as tunisia and egypt
all the way through persia and keep in
mind this is spreading overtaking
conquering what used to be controlled by
very powerful empires the easter the
byzantine empire or eastern roman empire
taking territory from them here and then
the and then sassanid persia taking
territory from them and this is less
than 30 years and then it spreads even
more during the next caliphate which is
now dynastic the umayyad caliphate by
the end of that at 7 50 ce you see islam
has now spread or conquered from modern
day spain and portugal all the way to
modern day india and pakistan
and we could continue this narrative and
we will continue to talk about it in
future videos but what's really
interesting is to think about how and
why it was able to spread this rapidly
there's very few instances in history
where we see this type of an empire form
this quickly and to get some context on
that we have this text here from the
american historian ira lapidus's book
islamic societies to the 19th century
and ira lapidus writes the expansion of
islam involved different factors in
different regions in north africa
anatolia the balkans in india so these
are regions that we aren't showing in
this map those happen later on after
outside of the period depicted in this
map it was carried out by nomadic arab
or turkish conquerors and so that is a
similar form method that we're talking
about though in this map in the indian
ocean and west africa it's spread by
peaceful contacts among merchants or
through the preaching of missionaries in
some cases the diffusion of islam
depended on its adoption by local ruling
families in others it appealed to urban
classes of the population or tribal
communities
the question of why people convert to
islam has always generated intense
feeling
earlier generations of european scholars
believed that conversion to islam were
made by the point of the sword and that
conquered peoples were given the choice
of conversion or death so a lot of
according to ira lapidus
these early european scholars viewed it
analogous to things like the spanish
inquisition or
some aspects of the crusades or some of
what we saw in the new world with the
conquistadors where it really was
convert or die but according to lapidus
it is now apparent that conversion by
force while not unknown in muslim
communities so in muslim countries so
there was some forced conversion but
according to lapidus was in fact rare
muslim conquerors ordinarily wished to
dominate rather than convert and most
conversions to islam or were voluntary
in most cases worldly and spiritual
motives for conversion blended together
and other re other sources i've looked
at do hint at these early caliphates
weren't that interested in conversion
they were clearly muslim and they were
also arab dominated
and they liked having this elite arab
muslim ruling class and they weren't
that interested in spreading the
religion and only when we get to into
the
abbasid caliphate where it becomes more
multicultural and more muslim and less
arab focused that you start to have more
and more conversions and the sources
i've seen have by the end of the umayyad
dynasty only about 10 to 30 percent of
the conquered people convert to islam
but much more convert during what's
often referred to as the golden age of
islam when islam is collecting the works
of the ancient greeks and the chinese
and the hindus and getting scholars from
all around the world under the abbasid
dynasty
now
what when lapidus talks about in most
cases worldly and spiritual motives for
conversion blended together he's
referring to these ideas that well maybe
for some people it just appealed to them
and you have to remember people weren't
going from being independent to being
subjugated in most cases even before the
conquest of islam they were probably
subjugated by a king or part of an
empire like the byzantine empire or the
persian empire and so they're really
switching from one conqueror to another
and often times people are hopeful that
the new conqueror might be better than
the last so often times they're proven
wrong sometimes it might actually be the
case and so there might have been some
support that allowed it to spread this
quickly
and there's also worldly motive motives
if there's a muslim ruling class and if
you want to be associated with that
ruling class that might be a worldly
motivation in order to actually convert
now the other thing that we do know
about these early muslim empires and
many of the muslim empires is they did
have this notion of dimi status
and dimi
is referring to the idea of protected
persons and it's often referred to as
people of the book but it include it it
included jews christians that islam
according to islamic tradition follows
in the same tradition of but then when
you eventually have muslim conquest of
india included hindus and buddhis
hindus and buddhis
as well and it also included
zoroastrians who the early muslims
considered to be
monotheistic and the idea of dimi status
is that they would have protected rights
they would have the same property
contract rights but different political
rights the the muslim ruling class
definitely had better political rights
and they would pay a different tax than
what the muslims actually paid
now in order to get context from a
religious point of view you can look at
some of the religious texts of islam
especially the koran and even the hadith
which are the the second hand accounts
of the life and practices of muhammad
and there you get an interesting
perspective and so on the side of
religious tolerance you have
excerpts like this there shall be no
compulsion in acceptance of the religion
unto you your religion and unto my
religion and from an ethnic point of
view there also seems to be a
you know a sense of non-superiority of
one ethnicity over another indeed
there's no superiority of an arab over a
non-arab nor of a non-arab over an arab
nor of a white over a black nor a black
of over a white except by piety towards
god and this is from muhammad's farewell
sermon
that's given by the hadith the life and
sayings of muhammad
now on the other hand there definitely
are more militant portions of the quran
one of the most quoted
excerpts is this one
and fight in the way of god those who
fight you but transgress not the limits
truly god likes not the transgressors
and kill them wherever you overtake them
and expel them from wherever they have
expelled you and persecution is worse
than killing and do not fight them at
the sacred mosque until they fight you
there but if they fight you then kill
them such is the recompense of the
disbelievers and if they cease then
indeed god is forgiving and merciful
fight them until there is no persecution
and until worship is acknowledged to be
for god but if they seize then there is
to be no aggression except
except against the oppressors
so a critical view of this is saying
look this is
clearly advocating to kill
other people
and fight those who are considered to be
disbelievers that's clearly a critical
view of this and you will not see this
type of language for example and
more pacifist notions of say the gospels
and it's the gospels and it's definitely
not the notion the modern notion that we
have of passive resistance or peaceful
resistance in the notion of
a gandhi or a martin luther king now
those who would defend or see a little
bit more nuance here would say look
you've got to this is not talking about
killing disbelievers arbitrarily this is
talking about killing those who are
persecuting you and they would say look
this revelation is believed according to
islamic tradition to have come down
when the muslims were actively being
persecuted by muhammad's tribe the
quraish they were in medina they were
essentially in exile and they were in
fear for their lives muhammad's own life
their quraish had attempted to kill him
they were torturing and killing that
early muslim community and in that
context they're saying and fight the way
of god those who fight you so it's
really out of defense trying not to be
persecuted but transgress not the limits
and even there there are rules of law
here or rules of engagement and kill
them wherever you overtake them and
expel them from wherever they have
expelled you and persecution is worse
than killing and so this is creating a a
moral hierarchy that is very debatable
especially amongst in modern times is
persecution is persecution worse than
killing and do not fight them at the
sacred mosque so this is really seems to
be referring to the quraish because
remember they're fighting over this
notion of what even should happen at the
sacred mosque
until they fight you there but if they
fight you then kill them such as the
recompense for the disbelievers and if
they cease then indeed god is forgiving
and merciful so to some degree those who
would be who would see the nuance in
this passage they say hey look this is
talking about killing those who
persecute you but it actually seems to
be a little bit more conciliatory than
remember the quran is according to
islamic christian built on the
traditions of the old testament and on
christian traditions and especially
relative to the old testament which
tends to be much more absolute when
someone is disliked by god they just you
know whole
whole cities or peoples are are
destroyed or killed or god might command
there has prophets and the leadership to
kill other people just because they
displeased god in the old testament
people who would defend this passage
or see nuance here says look this is
about being persecuted and fighting
persecution and even if those and if
those persecutors stop then don't seek
revenge they and if they seize and
indeed god is forgiving and merciful and
there is to be no aggression except
against the oppressors so i'll leave it
to you to decide i encourage you to look
up your own primary resources look up
different translations one of the the
tricky things of not just the quran but
including the bible which is believed to
first be written in aramaic or the old
testament the torah written in hebrew is
that the translation itself can also
give you various nuance but make your
own decisions about what you think
is or your own judgments of what we've
talked about in this video